(speaking in foreign language)
- Some property developers in China
are going to great lengths
to attract home buyers.
(speaking in foreign language)
One offered cars and
parking spots as a gift,
while another promised to
give the buyer a Mercedes-Benz
with the purchase of a villa.
One developer even
offered to accept garlic
as part of the down payment.
The ads suggest that for
Chinese property developers,
demand is down.
Since the summer of last year,
home sales for China's 100
biggest property developers
have tumbled.
Home sales, of course, are
not just struggling in China,
in the Western world as well.
Home sales have been under pressure
after record surge in prices.
Inflation has become a problem
and fears of a recession are growing.
But in China, there are a
number of different factors,
including concerns about the debt levels
of property developers,
as well as COVID 19 lockdowns.
China is the world's
second largest economy,
so anything that happens
within its own borders
and in its own economy
has ripple effects for
the rest of the world.
So here's how the government
and property developers
are rolling out measures
to help boost home sales.
China's real estate market has become
perhaps the most important industry of all
in China's economy.
The estimates tend to be
that the real estate market
accounting for between 25%
even up to one third of China's economy.
Home prices had just gone up
every year for several decades.
It also enriched a lot
of property developers
and had them trying to
race ahead of one another
to buy more land and to
bring in more presales
so that they could fill their coffers
and buy ever more land.
And that model was perhaps
most clearly exemplified
by a company called Evergrande,
that is one of the country's
biggest property companies
as well as one of the most indebted,
it quickly found itself pushed
to the brink of collapse.
Chinese regulators last year began to take
the most concrete steps
that they have taken yet
to try and curb developers' debt levels.
(protesters speaking in foreign language)
That created a crisis at Evergrande,
which jolted consumer
confidence in the market,
causing concerns about
China's economic growth
as well as whether other
real estate companies
could fall too.
In addition to the regulatory pressures,
developers also faced another foe
in the form of COVID 19 lockdowns.
It kept potential home buyers
in many cities and provinces
across China, home bound.
So both property developers and
Chinese government officials
have started to take some steps
to arrest the slide in home prices,
and maybe even to perk
them up a little bit.
On the government side,
officials in dozens of cities
and other jurisdictions across the country
lowered mortgage rates
and made it easier to buy an apartment,
if you're young and on the market.
Meanwhile, among property developers,
they're advertising free
gifts with a home purchase.
Some have gone to even
more creative measures.
For example, one company is
giving out an actual pig,
while another is offering
job opportunities.
The response from the Chinese
public has been mixed.
If you look online,
you'll find some comments
that talk about interest
in buying an apartment,
but you also see some
skepticism online too.
It does seem gimmicky to some people,
and for many people,
the question is whether
or not they feel confident
going out and buying an apartment.
The real question, of course,
is how effective these policies can be.
It's probably gonna rely more
on big macroeconomic factors
rather than on what freebies
developers throw in,
or what incremental loosening measures
one's city or town has.
To build at the pace
that China has been building
at for the last few years
consumed a vast quantity of inputs
that were acquired from
outside of the country.
So any sharp slowdown
that we see in housing
is gonna have impact on
commodity producing countries
all around the world.
And so that is something
that people all around the
world are gonna be watching,
whether the Chinese home buyer comes back,
and whether these developers
survive and thrive.
(bright music)